[Música]
a escala en parís
aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y france 24
un tanto particular hoy porque el
confinamiento en francia nos obliga a
entrevistar a nuestro invitado a
distancia hoy hace escala en parís el
escritor miguel von fue para
presentarnos su última novela y rita de
herencia en español muchísimas gracias
miguel por estar en línea con nosotros
muchas gracias
bueno antes de hablar de esta última
novela de este libro fabuloso quería
preguntarle cómo está llevando el
confinamiento y si es de esos autores
que encuentran inspiración en estas
circunstancias sin embargo se la quita
completamente lo estoy llevando bastante
bien me tomó tiempo para leer más que
para escribir en este momento de la
joyería y tejer uno escribe poco porque
está más bien defendiendo del libro
anterior pero estoy leyendo con mucho
gusto alexander y mal lo contó
montecristo en este momento y estoy en
y entonces muy buena compañía vamos a
presentar un poco sus credenciales en
miguel boom fue es francés de madre
venezolana y padre chileno sus dos
primeras novelas el viaje de octavio y
azúcar negro fueron muy aplaudidas por
la crítica y traducidas a varios idiomas
y esta tercera cita es publicada por la
editorial el vals está teniendo muy
buena acogida hasta el punto de haber
estado en las listas para el goncourt
que es el premio literario francés más
prestigioso en rytas es la historia de
una saga familiar francesa en chile los
land son ya que inicia en 1873 un
viticultor del lugar en el este de
francia que decidió dejar esas tierras
porque su viña se echa a perder con la
plaga de filoxera y su objetivo es
instalarse en california pero el azar o
el destino para que desembarque en chile
donde se sucederán cuatro generaciones
hasta
y la ayuda su padre el padre de miguel
vuelve a francia porque quiso contar
esta historia familiar cuando le nace
esa necesidad de contarla pienso que
tenía ganas de hablar y rendirle
homenaje a mi padre a la historia
terrible en la negra mitología que pudo
vivir en la tortura en villa grimaldi
durante la dictadura
él escribió un libro cuando llegó a
francia en el 74 donde un testimonio
sobre la tortura y habla claramente
dando detalles terribles de todo lo que
sucedió el libro se llama relato en
frente chileno fue publicado en
barcelona- y cuando yo lo leí hace unos
años porque no me había atrevido a
leerlo antes pensé que era importante
poder vestir ese libro de toda una
historia familiar entonces fui pensando
e imaginarme la generación anterior
después la generación de antes la
generación de antes y me di cuenta en
verdad que tenían un siglo perfecto ya
que él había llegado en el 73 a francia
pero su tatarabuelo se había ido de
francia en 1873 huyendo justamente esta
crisis de filoxera
las parras francesas como se dice en
chile entonces era perfecto para mí
crear un círculo narrativo entre 1863 de
1970 ante una primera migración de
francia chile después de chile a francia
y tener dos guerras mundiales y una
dictadura encima de esa estructura
efectivamente es la historia también de
idas y venidas como cuentas entre entre
chile y francia
y habla usted de la dictadura chilena
del golpe de estado de ese homenaje que
le quería hacer también a su padre pero
tal tal vez sea un homenaje también a
esos chilenos a esos latinoamericanos
que viviendo en latinoamérica se fueron
a luchar en la primera y segunda guerra
mundial a un país francia defender un
país que ni siquiera conocía había esa
historia tal vez sea bastante
desconocida no efectivamente ese
extraordinario de darse cuenta la
cantidad de latinoamericanos que
decidieron irse que son hijos de
inmigrantes y que decidieron irse de
francia este llegará a chile argentina
venezuela instalarse y cuando la primera
guerra mundial llegó la noticia y la
primera guerra mundial tuvieron como una
especie de deseo ardiente una especie de
necesidad casi biológica o telúrica de
agarrar unos barcos de volver
europa y pelearse contra hermanos
alemanes que a veces hacían parte de los
hijos de la inmigración alemana que en
el final del siglo 19 habían llegado a
europa entonces esa especie de
absurdidad patriótica la de poder cruzar
un océano entero para ir a pelearse y
defender una bandera que uno no conoce
de ir a defender una tierra que casi no
conoce un idioma del que el que habla
poco entonces inmediatamente me pareció
que ese absurdo me podía dar un poco de
relato podía dar un terreno para crear
este una situación narrativa compleja
por eso entonces me permití simplemente
el lujo de poner estas dos guerras
mundiales y entonces de alguna manera
rendirle homenaje también a todo el psoe
latinoamericano que decidieron partir
para contribuir y participar a esos
esplendores y esas horas negras de las
guerras francesas como consigue armar el
puzzle genealógico y encontrar los
elementos para forjar la personalidad de
cada personaje
por esta el primer las uniendo el
primero el viticultor esta elijo las que
además en lázaro es un nombre muy muy
evocador no es el que el que renace en
la biblia luego esta mago y luego está
su padre hilario da creo que había una
pieza del puzzle que no está muy clara y
que tuvo que tirar de un personaje
digamos extranjera a la familia
absolutamente sí todo es un sistema de
equilibrio
tenía ganas que las cuatro generaciones
tengan la misma cantidad de páginas y
que cada personaje en cada generación
tenga un peso un espesor un relieve
exactamente idéntico al de los otros
el primero naturalmente este viticultor
que está viviendo la crisis de filoxera
era el luz soñé después venía su hijo
las aves que según lo que me han dicho
es mi tatarabuelo el millwall que estuvo
en la primera guerra mundial y
efectivamente al final tenía hilario
edad que era mi padre y quería cerrar el
círculo narrativo con él en el medio
tenía un hueco o decidía ir a buscar en
mi historia familiar de hablar de mi
abuela o de mi abuelo que tuvieron una
historia fascinante o al contrario me
permite el lujo de la libertad de
inventar a alguien pero finalmente fue
una tercera opción ya que caí por azar
sobre la historia de mcgowan de esta
aviadora franco-chilena que había
estudiado en escuelas de pilotaje en
chile que la segunda guerra mundial
decide seguir el llamado de sóftbol en
inglaterra se pelea contra los alemanes
y finalmente vuelve a chile y muere en
chile la historia de ella es totalmente
fascinante decidí simplemente agarrar
algunos elementos que me interesaban
poder tejer los otros elementos
de la historia de los personajes y
entonces poder como fundir la historia
de magia
en esta especie de rompecabezas de los
otros personajes no sólo una novela
histórica no sólo una biografía de su
familia e impresión que me ha dado
también a mí es de una fábula no de un
libro si me permite también de aventuras
donde lo sobrenatural los fantasmas
juegan un papel esencial en la trama
donde los muertos vuelven y en cada uno
de los miembros de esta saga hay una
especie de obsesión para unos es la viña
para otros la música para otros la
aviación para otros los pájaros
con los pájaros además hay como una
especie de alegoría desde algo muy
metafórico
miguel usted escribió en francés pero yo
diría que es una literatura bastante
latinoamericana no no si me explico y si
se reconoce en esa tradición literaria
en latinoamericana por supuesto yo crecí
en venezuela en parte también en
argentina en parte en chile pero también
mucho en francia en portugal también un
tiempo en italia ya que el libro fue
escrito en la biblia me dices en roma'
entonces yo siento en mi corazón que
está en estas dos culturas que está este
puente entre dos continentes e intento
con tener las dos inspiraciones las dos
influencias y dejarme llevar por esos
dos ríos que llegan a un mismo mar por
un lado hay una estructura muy
latinoamericana con personajes muy
latinoamericanos donde yo también he
tenido de influencias de lectura como
bolaños como neruda como vargas llosa
como césar vallejo como alejo carpentier
como juan rulfo así que han sido para mí
lecturas importante durante el libro y
también isabel ahí
naturalmente ya que es con su primer
libro y en francia yo estuve leyendo
mucho ellos es que es el mismo
mike mills y ojo que fueron mis lecturas
y michel tony durante la escritura
intenté de manera no sé si buena o mala
simplemente poder hacer un cruce una
especie de mestizaje literario a ver si
podía encontrar un punto de encuentro
entre los dos detener de un lado el
rigor francés y del otro la fantasía
latinoamericana
le quería preguntar miguel usted qué
obsesión heredad de su familia cuáles
son sus obsesiones
cuáles son los fans los fantasmas que le
acechan de esa sangrienta pregunta
pienso que es probablemente una especie
de necesidad epidérmica de contarlo todo
entonces a cada vez que me sucede algo
siempre tengo la pregunta primera que me
llega al espíritu cómo lo voy a contar y
quizás mi padre por ser escritor y haber
efectivamente escrito el testigo del
testimonio de ésta
dictadura por otro lado mi martes se una
gran lectora de borges y de poema
también mi familia teniendo una especie
de vieja herencia de literaria y
artística era como evidente de alguna
manera de que pasar de una idea
abstracta y ponerle en palabras era
probablemente una de las mismas grandes
obsesiones y ya para terminar no nos
queda mucho tiempo miguel le quería
preguntar que cuando podremos leer esta
novela en español
bueno fíjese que chile la compró con la
magnífica editorial lom paulo esta
chiquis y luego hilera también en españa
la editorial armenia con ricardo lópez
la compraron también van a ser una misma
traducción así que normalmente yo creo
que en 2021 máximo 2022 tendremos con
suerte herencia en español pues
muchísimas gracias miguel bonfá por esta
entrevista y le deseamos un muy buen
confinamiento con el conde de
montecristo
gracias y muchísimas gracias a todos
ustedes por habernos acompañado ya saben
que nos pueden seguir por internet en rf
y mundo.com france24 puntocom hasta
pronto amigos
[Música]
[Aplausos]